welcome back to CBS mornings or should I
say The Price is Right two hours of news
and other stuff the most fabulous time
you can have in the morning and we are
looking for a brand new contestant Vlad
gutier come on down
ey is a new father from New York New
York a former investment banker he knows
how to high five he hasn't had hair in
multiple decades also a veteran we are
very happy to welcome to the show Mr
dutier
ah how are you feeling this morning
we're doing good feeling good are you
excited you're ready to play and ready
to win baby all right and we're gonna
transition for a moment back to our
normal everyday characters I'm Tony
Nicole this is Mr dutier we are doing
this but no because TV's longest running
game show with the Price Is Right a show
we both love bidding farewell to the
only home it has ever known this is a
prop I'm gonna put it down after more
than 50 years of course the set of
Plinko the big wheel thousands of
showcase showdowns yes they are going to
close down for renovations Say It Ain't
So but the historic CBS show will move
to a new modern studio our Jamie West
got a final tour of the legendary Bob
Barker Studio at television City in Los
Angeles this is fun you should play I
Want to Hold It come on down you're the
first contestants on the new Pace he's
right after more than five Decades of
awarding new kitchens vacations and of
course brand new car changes ahead at
Hollywood's legendary television city
were you aware when you game that you
were here on such a historic day no no
we actually
know
these folks in line are among the last
audience members to watch The Price is
Right at stage 33.
the Bob Barker Studio what do you think
you'll miss most about this place
specifically the bad Wi-Fi
I'm the last one to host the prices
right here in the stage 33. here's your
house Drew Carey has hosted here since
2007.
nine years ago I sat in maybe the same
chair with you what's changed for you
about this job I mean you still grew a
beard let my hair grow out I know I mean
you look very you look more relaxed you
look you look funkier and a little more
change my wardrobe I want to try to
never wear a tie again the rest of my
life
but it was in 1972. when iconic host Bob
Barker first stepped onto this stage
beginning a 35-year run of explaining
games I want you to make out the check
are you ready I'm ready cheering
contestants on
and cementing himself in pop culture
history have your pets spayed or
neutered but it's the contestants on
this stage who make it memorable says
announcer George Gray you cheer for them
like crazy to win that doesn't happen in
a lot of competitions on Price is Right
it does you know you're booing
no everybody wants everybody to win even
those in the control room
can't help but take part
it takes a buzzing Hive of people to
move props and prizes fun ping pong
table all the models over the years have
used this set and props to their
advantage okay I'll have to show me your
Technique though because
Devin give me the like demo
okay
for the models this set has been more
than just a workplace I just remember
all the special moments that were cheers
here like when I became a citizen
ocean is not lost on Carrie Bob Barker
was here for 35 years I'm here 16 years
16 years is not it's not nothing but
it's not 35. you know I don't they don't
have a they don't have a mural of me on
the wall but the fact that I'm here and
I'm the last one to host this price is
right here and they're trusting me to
move it along to Glendale and start the
whole stage again
I feel pretty good about that it's a
pretty good honor here we go the price
is right's new home is in a studio just
12 miles away but Die Hard fans rest
assured the set will look mostly the
same George Gray let's get another
contestant out here he got an announcer
George Gray's familiar calls come on
down is making the move too
[Music]
all right that last show from Bob Barker
Studio airs Monday right here on CBS but
right now we're going to play a little
bit of prices right a little guessing
game Bravo to Drew Carey though bravo
bravo tomorrow
serious we need the price tag stickers
for all come on all right but all of you
stay up right there okay
[Music]
okay how does this work this work go
ahead we're gonna see who gets the
closest to these prices without going
over your Windbreak actual retail price
the actual retail price
all right first we have Kraft original
mac and cheese dinner
did we see it okay everybody have an
idea what that cost so I mean I can give
you like a New York Bodega price and
then I can give you like the price I
think it is in Ohio I'm gonna go with
4.99 okay
[Laughter]
no I would guess I think it's high too I
was going to say 2.99 three dollars all
right Vlad I was I thought Tony was a
little too high too I'm going to say uh
299 did you say 299
three dollars okay you went up actually
you're all over it is 1.19 wow
all right now we have a GE Profile Ultra
fast combo washer and dryer this is high
okay washer and dryer I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go 7.99 oh 100 709 go ahead I'm
gonna say 2 000. uh 1200. all right Gail
you've got it and now we have my
favorite the 2023 Ford Mustang Machi
we're gonna have to leave that I'm gonna
leave that one alone
up next look at all that matter this
week don't forget to have your pet
spayed or not right